it came to a crunch point where I said
no I'm not going to sign over the house
to you that's not happening then
suddenly um one morning on my door um as
a police they copied me off to the
police station uh and I had I've been
accused of rape and child molesting of
my daughter and once we got divorced I
knew regardless of how I felt what my
children needed and that was him
regardless and I knew also from my faith
what was his right and I could not take
that away from him and the only problem
here is a lot of women that now I coach
they are very scorned and they're bitter
and they do want to take it out on the
other person when I'm like you know what
you're hurting your child I got to a
situation where my children suddenly
were cut off from me by the mother she
wouldn't let me um see them like he went
to these like partners and said to them
like do you love your kids yes I'll die
for them forget die for them you're
killing you you're killing them I didn't
want him to be part of my son's life
anymore but it's only until now that
I've done the work that I realized that
it wasn't about my son all along it was
about me it was about how I felt towards
him that I was inflicting onto my child
not only by themselves they've got a
collective behind him mum dad brother
sister pleasant friends friends a lot of
friends friends a lot of friends yeah
what struck me was look you identified
who the real winner is the children you
know fathers we want you know our sons
to become like us and and they should
because that masculinity that comes from
a man can only come from a father a
woman can never give that no matter how
much we try we can never we can never
fulfill the role of a father men are
very silent we don't talk about our
problems and this is what puts us in a
downward spiral that makes us go commit
suicide depression and all these other
things
no
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a southern for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
award click the link and donate what you
can
for the most trust or Praises glory and
gratitude belong to him our aim with
this show with our guests is our
honorable sisters and our honorable
brothers and myself is to help the
breakdown of the family unit which we
can see so that's one of the reasons I
started this show um and may Allah bless
them because without the guests we there
won't be a show
um so today's topic is actually
something um
I have
heard of somehow witnessed not myself
and it's a disturbing issue and the
brother who actually organizes to invite
I will guess which I'm going to go to in
a minute uh he's been telling me about
this issue for a long time and I know
many men who have been going through
this uh personally and I didn't get the
chance to do that because I really
wanted to do justice to it it's easy to
just do a face-to-con video but I really
wanted to do justice to it by talking to
real people who are living living this
um in this situation so yeah let's get
straight into it before we start I just
want to make a few things clear um
obviously we're Muslims we know not foul
language
backbiting let's be careful to
backbiting it can be unintentional but
let's just be careful too because we've
got many other topics which we're going
to discuss and that's it other than that
disagree in a respectful manner you can
you know raising your voice doesn't mean
you're being rude it's fine if you're
passionate just don't raise it too high
but that's it so let's start off with
our guests please tell us a bit about
yourself inshallah I'm going to give you
my mic because we've got one magazine so
yeah please tell us about what you do
and oh sorry today's topic is basically
in a nutshell
um fathers who are not able to see their
kids okay so uh basically
um please tell us a bit about yourself
and send it to this topic what is it
that you do
my name is Ahmad Raiden
um I'm a member of the Muslim father
support Forum uh what we do is basically
we help fathers get back and get access
to their children by the courts
um and we see many cases of others using
access and then we help them through
basically the whole court process
so that's us
my name is gold uh similarly I work with
the uh um with the Muslim father's
support from I've been involved because
of uh my situation uh and and my
involvement personally
um with my children and how I had to uh
fight uh to get gain access to the
children so I've been there I've done
that I've got the experience and I
understand and feel what other fathers
are going through and this is what I
want to do I want to contribute uh you
know in supporting and helping other
Fathers as well to get back their
children Michelle and that's one of the
reasons uh we invited the brothers
um and well the sisters they've been
here before you can maybe give a little
introduction about yourselves
hi my name is
my name is Amira
um yeah I'm just getting into this
podcast thing
um you know thing and inshallah you guys
will see more of me and more of my input
in femininity and just how to be a
better person in general
okay
my name is Ira I work in a school and a
contact creator
assalamu alaikum Muhammad I'm a
broadcaster TV presenter and producer as
well as a life coach helping clients
through their issues and this is
definitely one topic that I definitely
have loads of case studies for and being
divorced myself gone through sort of
like separation with children involved
um definitely want to highlight some of
the positivities of when you do things
in a particular way that it can actually
work so yeah inshallah will go into it
okay that's fine perfect you guys
inshallah so just introduce a bit of
others
and that's the sound that it makes but
basically if you have an opposing view
to the other side or you can be just you
know
um you when you press that you get one
chance to press it on the show it gives
you a chance of one and a half minutes
to speak nobody can interrupt it's just
there for that so if you somebody says
something and you just want to cut them
in a respectful way it's you can use
that inshallah so let's get straight
into it um so I want to hear some
stories first so because you guys think
you have experience at the topic in hand
pertaining to fathers we will have a
topic pertaining to also sisters where
the fathers disappear from the kid's
life as well so let's just be just in
that as well but today's topic is
specifically this what stories or things
that you have gone through personally
yourself you're comfortable discussing
what is going on like I really want to
know what is going on okay so I'll talk
a bit a bit about my story my journey to
the Muslim father support Forum so in
2010 I split from my then wife
um and we had two children together
for five years after that after we
partying on good terms I even did the
traditional thing or the Islamic thing
of giving a gift as you part which is
part of the part of the dean and for
five years alhamdulillah everything was
good I had the kids every weekend they
were with me things are cool between me
and the other party
um and that was my five years in 2015
um I got married again
that's when trouble began
um and then so one part of this is we
had an agreement so we had only an
Islamic marriage
so we had a house well it was my house
under Sharia I paid for it but I said
look you know what I'll do is I'll pay
this house off and I'll give it to the
kids because obviously generational
wealth all that you know I wanted them
to be secure
and that was our agreement and that was
an agreement for five years
so I got married then suddenly I
received a letter from a solicitor her
solicitor saying that first she started
off with oh I'm gonna go to Dubai and
take the kids
then suddenly that switched to well no I
want the house you have to give me the
house and I'm like but you know it's in
it's my property you know we've already
agreed that I'm going to give this to
the kids
so that began the process
um we had a bit load of back and forth
um and I'll cut that short to basically
it came to a crunch point where I said
no I'm not going to sign over the house
to you that's not happening you know I'm
willing to put it into a trust so I know
it goes to the kids because that's what
we agreed but anything other than that
I'm not agreeing to
then suddenly um one morning on my door
um as a police
they copied me off to the police station
uh and I had I'd been accused of rape
and child molesting of my daughter
um
now it's just to clarify the rape
allegations were of about for 2010 time
so that was my journey into this um and
basically at the end of it was I gave up
my house I said look all right here you
are take what you want here you are let
me see the kids and the words were no
you know um you're gonna have to go
through Court
now at this point my kids were older
they've been poisoned against me
and they don't know the truth uh and
furthermore
um at the time I had some legal advice
which I actually found out that later
when I started to look into things
myself which was wrong which was that
basically because there's allegations
against my daughter that my daughter
would face a physical examination
and as a father I couldn't deal with it
I'd wake up one minute like nah that's
it younger yeah I'll do it I'm gonna
yeah go with it then you'd come to the
evening be like no and that's that was a
term of three weeks to the point I just
said no you know what as a dad I've got
to protect my daughter this is this is
this is the hit I've got to take the uh
so from that
um
that was my story so I started to look
into it and start to see a pattern of
behavior
um and from that pattern um I started to
help other brothers well just generally
anybody in the Muslim normal stem
um but then I start to slowly notice a
pattern of Muslim men turning up
and the Muslim men experience is worse
because we get the standard allegations
made in court and we get the extra of
our religious uh beliefs as well yeah
and these are from practicing sisters
exactly and obviously technical bit
Earth you know as a Muslim man in court
with the name Muhammad and so on it
doesn't bow well in that Arena
so we started off basically a Facebook
page started off with about three four
people because I started to create this
Lane because we know that we had a few
Muslim brothers that's helping
and from that
this was a kind of maybe in March 2020
and now to present day we've got about
550 Plus Brothers you know Facebook
Forum
Muslim father's support Forum we're on
Twitter uh Instagram uh Facebook and
we've also got the uh web page which is
mfsf.uk if anybody needs help they can
contact us through those means
yeah so that's that's just there okay so
yourself brother good yeah yeah did you
go through something similar like this
to I mean this is this is to me that's
horrific it's these accusations are not
it's not a joke no
um but yeah please it's a very common
scenario though isn't it I mean mine
wasn't as Extreme as that
um my situation was a very simple one
yeah but it was made complex by by the
system so to speak the family court
system and all these agencies
yeah so um you know
um I won't go into too much detail but
uh I got to a situation where my
children suddenly were cut off from me
by the mother she wouldn't let me
um see them and the only recourse I had
really because I didn't I wasn't
involved with the msf uh msfs SF uh
prior to that was to go through the
legal route uh get a solicitor who
understood you know what the process was
and everything else uh we tried to
mediate with the mother
um to say look everything was fine uh
children are living with me and the
mother you know 50 of the time let's
just maintain that yeah but I think uh
the family's court system and just the
the all the various agencies they
emboldened her I believe to think that
you know you can you don't need to give
the children back you can come out you
know have you can raise various false
allegations and just uh State whatever
you want did you did you was you accused
of anything
molestation order on me okay but I mean
really if you look at it it's it it's
not funny but it's all you know it was
laughable initially my initial reaction
was some you know the statements that
were made in there
um you know you think how do they get
away with it but that's beside the point
uh alhamdulillah you know uh uh I went
through the system uh halfway through uh
going to the I can't even remember how
we got in uh kind of uh uh in touch but
we did I got in touch with the brothers
I realized that the solicitors they're
just there to prolong cases and get
their paychecks and then the brothers
came along uh they took on my call uh my
case
um and uh we just we just got through
the various uh legal uh uh system and I
managed to get my children uh you know
at 50 50 which is what I originally lost
okay but unfortunately it only meant
that I've I mean this isn't a big issue
for me I ended up spending about 15 000
pounds literally just down there but to
me I would do that a thousand times to
get access to my children it's as simple
as that okay
so moving on to our sisters I don't know
if you guys are experiencing sister
fahima you said you're obviously
divorced you've got kids Abdullah
um and I doubt you're a person who
stopped your seeing their father please
tell us a bit because I really want to
know what is going through the mind of
our sisters I mean this is these are
Muslim sisters who are supposed to be
God-fearing who are the form of room and
to cut kinship as a major sin it is a
major sin it says it is to cut the
kinship is a major sin so from a
sister's perspective maybe you guys and
the rest as well can you please tell us
a bit about what is going through their
mind because to me I see some trigger
points off he got married again
um he got divorced and then he got
another wife I'm being honest and I hear
this a lot please enlighten us maybe
inshallah please
um I can state from a lot of
perspectives because aside from my own
obviously I coach clients but I did that
after I was divorced and I actually
worked on myself and my home so I was
you know a traditional wife and stayed
at home and unfortunately my ex-husband
found that boring after a while and
wanted to go elsewhere but we are both
single he hasn't moved on and once we
got divorced I knew regardless of how I
felt what my children needed and that
was him regardless and I knew also from
my faith what was his right and I could
not take that away from him and the only
problem here is a lot of women that now
I coach
they are very scorned and they're bitter
and they do want to take it out on the
other person when I'm like you know what
you're hurting your child more
importantly so I feel that you know me
I'm very blessed and I'm very lucky
because even now my ex and I co-parent
extremely well we have an amazing
relationship regardless of how we ended
because I make sure that he is involved
with the kids not because of me but
because of them and I had to put myself
aside no matter what I felt and now we
have such an amazing Dynamic probably
better than most people that are even
married because I created that because
firstly I had to think about what was my
responsibility as a mother for my two
boys and what they needed and even
though the father at the time was also
like not happy about you know
the situation as to being separated and
you know not being there emotionally I
pulled him towards them I pulled him
towards them and I pulled them towards
him when they felt even uncomfortable
because I knew that that's what I had to
build and when I have clients now that
go through this I'm like forget your
feelings because the relationship is
done but what's important and you have
to take responsibility is those children
islamically and psychologically they're
the ones that's going to suffer because
you can move on even to a second wife or
a husband or whatever but they have to
come first and that's generational what
they're going to go through so I really
do come on really strong on women as
well because when a woman is scorned
they don't see nothing and I'm the first
one to call them out to say you know
what you need to stand back and you need
to realize that no matter what that
person did to you even if it was abuse
you have to do it in the proper way but
he still has some sort of access it was
through the courts whether it's like
through you know some sort of like
access through uh you know what's it
called where you have to have yeah so
basically you know you have to do
something where it's like you know a
sort of a medium that's there but they
still need that so I really am
passionate about this topic and I am
successful with my coaching because I
had to do it myself for my home and if I
wasn't on point with my ex with my
children and mashallah you know they are
so good with their mindset having both
of us and having The Best of Both Worlds
because even though it was difficult for
me to deal with
it was something that I had to do and
yes okay he did not get married again
he's still not married again maybe that
could have caused issues but the way I
think to be honest I would say as long
as the second wife was good to my
children they have a second person to
turn to you really have to lower
yourself and we don't do that we don't
do that because we just get jealous we
want to be the one on top we want to be
to get back and all of these things and
it really does not serve anyone least of
all your children so I'm thinking that
you know hopefully with this podcast and
people always you know assume the way I
speak as well is from my own experience
but they don't know my experience my
experience is actually quite unique and
the reason why I talk in certain ways
which is maybe controversial is because
I hear so many case studies every single
day from so many different people so I'm
the voice of the voiceless even if it's
not my scenario if it's not my situation
and I see both sides and I've had a lot
of men come recently to me telling me
how their wives have stopped their
children and I am really really
disappointed these are Muslim women who
are destroyed enjoying their future
children that's what they're doing
I mean initial sister FEMA you know
sometimes people I look at the comment
section and they say you know sometimes
I want to say that on life for me I'll
bless you you know like there's no
contributions you do but I mean I have
to put I mean after they salute you in
the and it's to me it's it's something
to be admired like what you just said
there I was like wow
yeah that's absolutely refreshing for us
to hear that as well you know
um exactly what you've kind of pitched
out
you actually nailed it because that's
the person you're hurting the most is
the child
when a child is not having access to
their you know the studies that show
that actually single parent homes you
know children tend to go off the rails
you know and they when they grow up they
grow with sort of anxieties and issues
which is problematic and that's you know
that's what we've got to tackle here
because what we're doing here through
this when we're going down this
particular path making father not see
you know there's there are some others
that don't get to see their children as
well you know we know about that yeah
but when you do things like that what
you're doing you're just destroying the
ummah that's it simple as that and
credit to you sister you know what it's
really good to hear a good co-pounding
story it really it's a rarity you know
I was speechless I'll be honest with you
not that I doubted the sister but you
know but it's to me it's like wow
because I've heard so many stories here
um it's refreshing it's refreshing you
have to we've got so many cases where
when Brothers do get access like you've
thought through Court you think right
I've come to the end of it
met the peace and just the happiness
begin for the kids and that but no it
ramps up ten times more and you're just
like as brother Matthew was saying you
know then she's not turning up then
you've got to do c79 application you've
got to go to court this that the other
oh don't do it again dear and that's it
and you know it's it's these are the
things and like he says the bandwidth
gets evaporated and then you know a lot
of women feel pain and they just don't
know how to challenge you know channel
that kind of pain so I worked on myself
and I knew and also I know my Dean I
know my faith very well I could not keep
my you know exes away from you know his
kids nor could I keep my kids away from
their father they need that so
importantly they need both parents there
and especially after divorce I have
proven I've broken the boundaries to
show that it can actually work it really
can and when you hold yourself back in
that way subhanallah so many
opportunities and things come to you
because of you you know lowering
yourself of course when there's abuse
and things like that you go through the
specific ways of you know dealing with
that those are extreme cases but
majority of the time it's just because
she's really scorned yeah yeah and you
know what that's the topic within itself
you know that I'm I'm trying to analyze
you and diagnose and I have a theory
which we can maybe discuss in a
different topic where this is stemming
from this why is sisters like so like
better than anger when it comes to
divorce Etc which we'll discuss another
topic about sister IRA and sister Amira
is there anything you would like to add
on if there's I do actually want to add
something
um
I believe it's genuinely stemming from
uh the fundamentals of what we are
teaching our children so the way women
are raised
um in certain cultures especially
especially within the subcontinent
we have this ideology that our children
belong to us
and we do not belong to us we belong to
the Creator so even with issues of you
know oh no you cannot marry this person
you cannot marry this your children are
picking up on these things and when they
do end up getting married and divorcing
then they have this also they have this
entitlement to their own children my
child is mine and they don't realize
that actually no it's in a union it's
it's a relationship you cannot withhold
an a manner a child which is gifted from
Allah between the man and the woman it's
in a manner and when you'd have that a
manner you have to know how to deal with
it and you have to understand that it's
a huge responsibility and if you take
your children especially in your case
and your situation my Father Allah used
to say one lie can cause two countries
to go to war so if a woman can lie and
say you did this or you did that you
have to understand what you're doing and
our kids it has to start from Young we
have to stop our children from lying
understanding that lies can really
affect even with girls and stop putting
such fragilities on women because they
can be you know very much they can they
can do these things they can lie and
then when it when they get into a
relationship and they are married and
they start revealing this bitterness and
this jealousy and this but this should
have been picked up in their childhood
because I guarantee you a lot of women
and girls you can see certain traits
from Young you know and it needs to be
stopped and vice versa for men as well
that's a really important Point she made
there because these women
um
the sisters that do this because on this
particular path they're not doing it by
themselves they've got a collective
behind them absolutely Mom Dad brother
sister friends friends a lot of friends
friends a lot of friends yeah you know
that are supporting them and like saying
yeah this this there and they'll pull
out they'll put out Islamic teachings
they'll pull out societal stuff they'll
to justify this and you know um but
again you know going back to what the
sister said there like in your situation
what struck me was look you identified
who the real winner is the children and
that's what's being lost here and like
you're saying sister you know we need to
stop pushing our
not even just the sisters I think
everybody you know the ummah tonight
being more truthful and more sort of the
down the lines of Dean and I think
that's what's been lost here because a
lot of people are living down the path
of Dean 90 but suddenly this 10 is
creeping in and that 10 is evaporating
the 90 exactly and we know that that the
the um the process of sell them you know
they went into an a war and there were
some captives and uh one of the women
lost their child so she was in like
where is my child with my child and the
process of selling points and I said you
see that woman do you think that woman
would ever throw her child in the fire
said never he said by Allah Allah is
more merciful than that woman but the
point here is what that mothers they
love for the children that that that
that woman was in like where is my child
now to think of mothers and you know the
Allah has given them that mercy and
empathy and compassion to them they're
literally attacking their own kids if
you think about it I love my kids so
much like he went to these like
ex-partners and he said to them like do
you love your kids yes I'll die for them
forget die for them you're killing them
yeah yeah we don't want you to die for
them you're killing them and it's a
selfish attitude it looks like you know
uh the the two kids of Adam where the
jealousy or whatever it was took consume
so much his hatred that he killed his
own brother so I think the hatred has
gone to that level sister Iris anything
like that yes so um can we have the mics
and I've also got a son alhamdulillah I
was in a very similar situation so when
my initial divorce took place there was
a lot of toxic feelings between both
parties and
um
I was convinced that I didn't want him
to be part of my son's life anymore
but it's only until now that I've done
the work that I realized that it wasn't
about my son all along it was about me
it was about how I felt towards him that
I was inflicting onto my child
and we don't realize that because the
mother's love for her child is
Irreplaceable and she will go beyond all
measures to protect and love that child
but often when we come out of a toxic
relationship whatever the reason may be
we label that man as he is now unfit
to not only be part of my life but also
the the child who is basically my life
and we then will do whatever it takes
hence the accusations the lies the
fighting not realizing that this
protection that we're giving the
childhood is actually toxic and even
though it comes from a place of goodness
because a mother's love isn't bad it's
still a negative and it takes a lot for
a woman to recognize that this is no
longer about my child or maybe it never
has been about my child but rather it's
about me and how I feel towards my
ex-husband and when a woman gets
divorced she's unfortunately
shamed and a lot of the time she is
blamed that it's her fault the marriage
broke down
so we often think he gave me the divorce
or even if I initiate the divorce and we
went ahead with it it's still his fault
because nobody wants to take an
accountability especially women we
struggle but we will blame him it's his
fault that he couldn't fix up his act or
he couldn't do this and he couldn't do
that therefore now I'm left on the side
because then no one's going to want me
and my child because I'm now divorced
and a single mom so in it in a way it
ruins our life and the only thing we can
do is make sure that doesn't happen to
our child but who's the person that
ruined our life is that is the father is
the dads the husband the ex-husband
but again that comes back to having that
toxic mentality and I think when a woman
starts to become aware of her emotions
and is able to differentiate what is her
experience what is her emotions and what
is the child's experience and emotions
she's been able to create that boundary
and that line to safeguard the child but
allow him allow the child to have that
relationship with the father and it's
taken me
I don't know four years to figure this
out
just what led you to that though you
know what helped you to get to come to
that realization or even beforehand what
made you like not one thing in the life
and then what made you change your mind
because that's very important for us to
understand so what made me so what first
major because you said it was a moment
where you said you don't want your child
to be involved in your response life
what led you to that and what made you
change so we can understand the before
and after sure it was fair it was fair
that my assignment was going to grow up
to become like him the man who hurt me
the man who ruined my life the man who
abused me the one who disrespected me
the one who took advantage of my
kindness or my love it was fair that my
son was going to become like him because
as
you know fathers we want you know our
sons to become like us and and they
should because that masculinity that
comes from a man can only come from a
father a woman can never give that no
matter how much we try we can never we
can never fulfill the role of a father
but when there is fear that he's going
to become like the man who I absolutely
despise because now we've labeled it as
he's the one that ruined my my life I
would then actually know it takes two
hands to clap I also ruined it again
it's coming back to taking
accountability which we don't do and I
think um it was only until I started to
work on myself as a person I had so much
bitterness in me and I was becoming like
a narcissist I hated it I hated who I
was I felt like I was just stuck and I
felt like
the world the universe everyone just
owed me because I had sacrificed so much
in my life and lost out on so much that
now it's my turn to be happy and I
couldn't get that because I was so toxic
and because of obviously what I was
doing and
um
when I began working on myself I
realized in in accordance to Dean as
well
that I actually had nothing I have no
power over this responsibility that
Allah has given me he is just a
responsibility he's not my property I
cannot stop what he does or who he sees
and especially not his own father
and I didn't have the best of all
relationship with my dad so I think that
really helped the situation because I
was like hold on I know how that makes
me feel today I wish I had that bond
with my dad and I don't I would know
when it ever want my son to feel like
that regardless of how his father is if
his father hits him tomorrow that's fine
we'll go to court don't do at least
tomorrow it won't be because of me or
you know I look around and some of my
friends or just people that I know their
son will be like approaching teenage
years and she'll say something like I
wish I had not stopped them from seeing
each other
and it's the thing is examples are all
around us it's just we need to open our
eyes and see the actual detrimental
effect that it's having on children
they're the innocent one here we cannot
use them to to express ourselves that
they're not an object they're humans
with emotions and with rights
sorry to cut but um although this you
know like I appreciate your situation
and I think that it's it's good that
you've come to that conclusion to allow
your son to see your child but Men Are
Not Angels as well in this situation and
of course I'm very much on the side of
women should allow their children to see
their fathers but there are situations
where the men use the children as
ammunition against the mother as well so
of course there's exception that for
example if we're talking about a father
who is dangerous to his children and
you've been falsely accused of these
things
um you know but if if a father is a
danger nobody's saying you know the
Sharia would not even allow that to
happen but we're not talking about so
when we said for example when I said to
the brothers that you shouldn't even be
why are you in that situation
you're looking from a different
perspective what we can't talk about
that because we're talking about you're
in a situation a predicament where
you're picking the two in your situation
what you're talking about is the man is
the oppressor he has to be in that
situation in the context where he's a
danger to his kids and uh so and he's
been and he's been and he's been felt
guilty what if it's not abusive okay so
Bad Manners
but the thing is I was speaking I can
remember about a year and a half ago
some sister I finished the student of
knowledge she contacted me I think she
wanted to invite me to some talk because
I cannot remember exactly well I think
there was some use doing some Madness
whatever I can't remember
she's talking to me and someone said to
me actually the person of knowledge Etc
I'm talking to talk to her the topic
went to somehow this issue yeah while
she was justifying to me that why the
sisters are right for not showing their
kids I was shocked well I I had to be
like well I said just like a refrain
that I thought maybe I misunderstood her
she was justified to me about how the
women are right to use the kids and I
said to her sister do you mean in the
sense of like the father's doing
something he's like no no you know if
she if he went and got married again
what are you talking about like oh I was
shocked I was like you you are the the
the the the the
Learned sister if you're doing this
we're finished and I'll be honest with
you these stories are petrified me so
much like it's a breath of fresh air to
hear sister for him or sister IRA and
sister uh Amira well I'll be honest with
you they've literally made me like well
hold on a second there are some there's
we haven't we can't lose hope because to
hear that from them to me and like like
may Allah bless you guys and especially
sister Arrow where she said she was
there and she's that realization to me
is like wow that's off to you wow hats
off to you the fact that you even
mentioned brave enough to say that today
um so it yeah I wanted to add in just
because you you've got a bad
relationship with or you had a bad
relationship with your ex-husband so he
was abusive verbally doesn't necessarily
mean he's going to be that towards the
kids I understand that if a man cannot
control his anger yes this likelihood of
him of it beating out when he is with
his children but you cannot just stamp
it as yes it's a failed relationship
because he behaved like that with me
therefore he will do the exact same
thing to the children true worse and
also in his PCC if we look at statistics
um I'm not being the sister a woman tend
to women are the ones that usually
actually uh end up not like hitting
their kids they know like the statistics
they show them from nspcc that the woman
are the main corporates when it comes
maybe because they spend more time with
the kids I don't know I'm not trying to
say all of them but they somebody can
use it a man can come and say you know
what you're more of a danger according
to statistics and I'd want them to stay
with me so
family court and Criminal Court are two
different things if you take a man of a
person to family uh to Criminal Court
you have to have clear evidence
to uh convict him in family court it's
done on probability the fact that you
are just together the probability is
already there the scale's there and what
you need so that probability counter if
he goes 51 one way that's it you're
guilty wow so that's so when you see
these things yeah and the thing is right
is inference hearsay and all these
things not actual evidence that's
convicting men in family court in my
okay that's interesting there's a thing
in my country and by the way we're not
asking anybody to beat their kids here
uh just before we yeah so in my country
they say if you don't um
smack your kids you will be smacking
your knees
Yeah so basically what that means is
like it can be that they die or it can
be that they go into a specific path
yeah so once again I'm not asking anyone
like when we're talking about beat here
I hope you get the gist yeah that's
interesting because the Sharia came to
like protect five things which is the
lineage the religion the Apple the
wealth and the health and if you look at
any of these five categories there's a
capital punishment all of them yeah uh
adultery we know what that is uh
stealing
um leaving the religion all that kind of
study there's Capital punishments and
against the deterrent because if you
think about it we talk about this who's
going to go and see two people
committing zinner
and you're seeing the act and you need
to be specific about it the whole point
is there's a deterrent uh but like you
said about the process of Islam I
haven't heard that before but again it's
there's like like in the Quran when
Allah says we have a dispute with your
wife talk to her move from the bed and
then you can do some kind of a force and
we know that force is very for example
you cannot leave a mark uh you cannot
cause pain so it is there but I'm
thinking in that category of course the
discipline is smacking the bomb Etc um I
I doubted that because some people can
take it like yeah the process them said
take a stick and start you know that's
not the case but what you're saying it's
true there should be some kind of
consequence now let's just it's the same
topic we just want to wrap up so for if
there is a brother out there who's going
through the situation
we know the sense of given amazingness
here to the sisters
too and this this is a phenomenon that's
going on it is happening a lot now yeah
and sometimes I talk about this and it
really annoys me because like there's
certain like we have Sisters
organization of sisters team there
sometimes we talk about these topics and
someone says that yeah but uh what about
what about I'm talking about that can
you imagine if imagine topic today is
men are beating their wives beating not
like beating yeah and then I go yeah
yeah but you know but what about the
brothers
anyways so the point is this it's always
mentioned what we're talking about now
is a phenomena that's happening I'm
hearing it left right center so it's
only just that we talk about this so if
you can speak to the men inshallah
brothers and tell them legally what they
can do if they are in a situation where
they they have been stopped by seeing
their kids and I heard the brother said
to me that I don't know if this is true
is
um that a brother took his own life
a week ago because he couldn't see his
children's yeah he killed himself is
this true yeah well if you look at it
statistically eight men a day they're
taking their lives
um you know and about I'd say half of
that is family related you know there's
been many men that through you know
Financial extortion through the child
maintenance service there's a system uh
people should take her name uh check her
out name sister Sally and Boris he sure
was a recommended to check up on her you
know she's doing a whole chunk of work
they've written a report and it shows
you
men that are committing suicide over
these matters see the Muslim
alhamdulillah because we know of the
last day we're just talking about this
in the car that this is the difference
because we know that we're going to get
the ultimate Justice after this
but you know for those that don't have
belief they turn to to suicide because
they don't see a light at the end of the
tunnel this is what it does and then you
also hear about brothers
you know obviously committing suicide
but also then losing their Dean losing
their practice and you know who's
picking up the tab on that well you know
I think people need to figure that out
so for brothers that are going through
this situation
if you can mediate let's try and let's
stop feeding the Beast of family court
currently you know I'd say on average is
about 4 000 Muslims in that Family Court
wow
that's too many right we shouldn't be
nowhere near that place we've got We've
Got Roots we can discuss
that's what we should be doing
um but that's not happening currently
because the systems gearing that think
about this the system is adversarial it
makes a winner a Newser
and right now
the courts sit on the side of women
whether we agree or not they can say
whatever but but from what we've seen
you know we're going into court with a
better argument and everything but
because it's a woman it's like the other
you know we're getting wiped
now
what I'm saying is we shouldn't be going
to this place even islamically I believe
in the Quran it says don't go to
man-made courts or you know you know the
city is enough but Muslims are
forgetting that you know
um so if you can mediate if you can't
mediate and you've got no other course
you can obviously go seek legal help
alternatively you can come see us at
mfsf.uk or Instagram or and all that
um and we'll we'll talk to us we'll
guide you and not only just there you'll
also meet other brothers that are going
through it and talking about it you know
because once you talk about it
especially talking to brothers that are
going through it we can help each other
lift each other men are very silent we
don't talk about our problems and this
is what puts us in a downward spiral
that makes us go commit suicide
depression and all these other things
don't you're not alone Brothers you know
come join us you know let's lift each
other up inshallah you know we'll find a
way
yeah and I think it's important to
understand that the Muslim father's uh
support Forum it's not about
supporting the father it's about
encouraging
um you know both parents to regain
access to their children so
unfortunately what happens is by the
time these brothers get in touch with us
they're already so deeply involved in
the court system and it's usually a case
of Team mother versus the team father
whereas it should be team parents trying
to find the best solution for the
children and that's what we we try to do
we try as brother Ahmed said you know we
will try and mediate uh we'll try and do
what we have to do for the the
betterment of the children yeah not for
the Batman of the father or the other or
even the mother but what is the best for
the children and you know it's it's
obvious that the the best interest in
the children is to have access to both
parents yes statistics show that I mean
it's clear it's detrimental it is
literally detrimental to the uh of the
family unit you know um yeah and that
that's what we need that's what we're
striving to do and we're striving to you
know obviously work with all the
authorities and so social services and
even the legal system to try and get a
resolution as as soon as possible so it
kind of minimizes as much disruption
um for the children and that's may I
bless you guys everything
but just touch up on that again the
situation that you're in I would
personally say personally to me I if I
was in that situation I would try my
best to fight for my kids this does not
mean just because I'm saying this that
oh I'm no because the Dilemma that one
is in it's such a like I'm being honest
to me it's like and I understand what
Robert Matt is coming from but to me
it's like my kids and especially a
daughter like to me specifically I've
been especially a daughter bro
I would say fight for it and inshallah
put your trust in Allah and one thing I
just want to touch my before going which
we miss and we need to incorporate this
here is taking the uncle over the
knuckle yeah what I mean by this is
taking your logic over what God
decreased and this is what this reason
why shaytan went straight because Allah
told him something but logically he said
no this is better for me you know why a
lot of sisters I believe are going
through this is because they are feeling
okay let's suppose the man was unjust
oppressing whatever it may be how many
of us have tawakon in Allah's Justice
you know why we do this because we're
seeing I don't believe in that and
because I don't believe in that I'm
going to carry the Justice out myself
because I don't trust Allah can do it
for me sometimes it's like that one line
let me tell us some I don't know stories
if you put your trust in Allah and you
believe this person really oppressed you
and wronged you why Allah is Justice
will be carried out believe me if you
genuinely have trust because
you're not going to cross the boundary
by not showing the kids you're not going
to do that you're going to go about it
the right way and believe me if you
genuinely have tawaku and Allah his
Justice would Prevail and if you have
that trust and because we don't have it
that's the reason why you got this
yeah the point is that so I would say
have trust in tawakul if you've been
oppressed rather than taken into your
own hands and causing Injustice which
you're going to go through in this life
in the Hereafter and your kids so it's
like a it's like a it's like a suicide
moment
everyone's going down
so just to add to my situation
um so after all this I can't after it
was all finished I was like you know
what that's it I went up with my life
and I met my wife we got married and at
the age of 45 I got blessed with twins
and I've got twins I see them every day
they're happy they're healthy they just
stops the house is full of love and
happiness and everything but my other
two children that I don't see
I still feel that pain
and that pain is what I turn into
mfsf into helping brothers because no
brother should feel what I feel that's
what I used it for so whatever we feel
we can use it for good bad this like the
other you know remember choices and I
appreciate your taking on it brother
Matthew you know I get that and I was
there at some point as well but but I
I've chose a different path and that's
you know that these are choices we all
have to make when that time comes but
you know it's just there just to give a
bit of take um bless you man I can hear
from your voice the pain you've gone
through and I can't blame both both I
can't but let's just end on sister
Island sister famous
um just to the women out there who are
possibly doing this like
honestly fear Allah because at the end
of the day you will not be buried with
your children you're gonna be buried
alone and if the father is there and
he's able and he's he will look after
the children and he is not a threat to
the children directly then you should
allow your children and for us for me
it's a very big indication that this
almost really failing and is in a bad
place that we are going to outside
sources like a lack of system which is
based on racism and built on racism we
never win in these courts as ethnic
minorities so if you are using that
system
it's already a big indication that this
almost really suffering at the moment
and we need to really take a big look at
ourselves to see what this issue is and
where it's stemming from and how we can
prevent this maybe some people shouldn't
be rushing into marriage just because of
marriage and having children not
everyone should just be rushing without
doing that groundwork first but yeah
that's me
sorry
um I think I just wanna
emphasize on um keeping your experiences
and emotions separate to your child
because you're not even though you're
one you're not one you know he's he or
she has her own individual life
and
just to if you are if you have come out
of the divorce I think it's very very
important to work on yourself
to find yourself again and to ground
yourself again because this divorce does
not define you
the way he treated you whether it was
abuse or not it doesn't Define you it's
up to you how you want to be defined if
you want to be that loving caring mother
then you can be that you don't have to
be the person who is so lost in her
emotions and is just out there to get
revenge
as our brother Ali said that Allah is
the most just and the Revenge that he
will get on your behalf is nothing in
comparison to what you can do who does
it that way yeah
so the Justice yeah yeah so just leave
that up to all the time and I think
that's where I found a lot of my piece
because I was done fighting there's only
so much I can do as a mother and I've
got so many roles I'm not just a mother
that's not my my only identity I'm also
a Muslim and I'm a woman and there are
things that I want to accomplish in life
and I can do that and by allowing the
father back into his life subhanallah
was the best decision I've ever made and
seven years later I can see them bonding
together and above all it's given me
some of my weekends back you know I kind
of like who you really get no I'm not
still with running around doing chores
no no that's that's a just a may Allah
about being a mother is the best thing
that you can ever be and I'm not that
I'm saying this because you know what
this feminist ideologist is you know
infiltrated you know we see that like oh
I'm not just a mother and I don't know
you don't mean it like that but you
being a mother what lies the best in
together and sisters like you we honor
and admire may Allah bless and preserve
people like you your mothers
alhamdulillah obviously this doesn't
mean you can have a job we talked about
his career we will discussed anyways but
yeah I just wanted to add on that
because some sisters feel like you know
I'm just someone no my life is such a
precious thing man it's it's amazing so
yeah please and it just gives you more
time as well too yeah
um study your aunt Dean because now you
don't have to worry about child care you
can go to his workshops you can go to
this lecture or just do whatever you
would want to do as within of the course
aligned with Dean so it's not always
have to be bad I think it's just taking
that initial step that's really daunting
but I think if you don't take that step
then you're never truly Gonna Know
sister can I just ask one question sure
obviously you know you had a toxic
relationship and you saw him as the
abuser now after you've seen him bonding
with with your son and you know you've
seen him being a father do you still see
him as an abuser
I don't
and I think it's not necessarily because
I've seen them born because I've only
just
started to see them on together but um
it was because I did a lot of work on
myself well because I I wasn't going to
let that Define me I was going to hold
it back and to be fair it's like I was
drinking the poison hoping he would die
wow you know and in reality it was just
me I was literally a deteriorating way
away in all in my hospitals have been My
Hope in Allah was being questioned
because I didn't know if you know like I
remember sitting in the courtroom and I
I was stuck there for about two hours
and I did nothing but pray that please
y'all let this go into my favor in the
family core which I now regret going to
and it didn't and it made me question
like like you you know my pain you know
what I'm going through you know what our
relationship was like so why yes okay
sister playing my quickly okay
um you know when you mention about
choosing those two regrets I had a
client recently as well who's you know
was taken away his kids were taken away
from him and he did he did choose to
walk away from that too not because he's
not choosing his children because the
women out of the system do do wanna you
know they do want to destroy him right
with money with Finance so even if he
was to fight for that he'd be end up
with nothing so it's not like as if
you're choosing that career or that
business you're doing it for your future
and for that family and you've got to
have trusted that because they're going
to come back to you and you're gonna
have to be somebody especially as a man
perfect very good right yeah so I think
it's really important that we understand
that they're not giving up on you
they're just looking forward and right
now they're not falling into the pit
that you're trying to put them in
exactly guys I think that was maybe the
most productive episode we've had may
Allah bless you guys inshallah amazing
amazing um uh yeah so that's it guys
from the bitter truth as you can see
with some Peter trips here especially
with that poison bar mashallah uh yeah
that's that's what it is and hope you
guys have benefited if you want to
suggest specific topics for us um email
inshallah at uh the bitter Truth at
bittertruthshop gmail.com uh if you want
to be a part of the panel please get in
contact with us inshallah until next
time
and we would like to also hear the other
side if there are sisters who have gone
through where the the fathers
disappeared or whatever maybe please we
would like to hear inshallah they'll be
one of our topics till next time
whoever builds a Mischief for the sake
of Allah Allah will build for him a
similar house in Jannah on that day when
Allah tells us that our books will be
given and every little atom weight of
Good Deed we've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and what a
lucky person which righteous person
Allah says this is for you for me yes
what did I do
you allow people to pray you built a
Masjid I never had the money to build a
master to Allah
it helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of
as they donate it now guys and do not
delay and and share the video for extra
Rewards
foreign
[Music]